hey friends and welcome back to my
channel in this video i'm going to
answer the question how many words do
you need to know in order to speak a
language fluently i'll cover how i
define fluency and how counting words
does or does not fit into my language
plans then i'll share all the ways i
approach learning words in my target
languages so you can apply the same
strategies to your own life and language
learning schedule hi i'm luca
lampariello i'm a language coach who
speaks 14 languages and on this channel
i help people learn foreign languages
more efficiently faster and in a fun way
now what does it mean to speak a
language fluently well the meaning of
the word fluently depends on your
definition of fluency i've talked about
my own definition of fluency in depth
elsewhere link in the description box
but here it is again the linguistic
ability combined with cultural awareness
to smoothly and confidently interact
with native speakers in a meaningful way
you may notice that this definition of
fluency refers only to speaking a
language with people the truth is though
that fluency comes in several forms
according to how a language is used just
as you can be a fluent speaker you could
also be a fluent reader a fluent writer
and a fluent listener fluency in one of
these areas however does not guarantee
fluency in others it's completely
possible for a person to be a capable
and competent reader of their target
language for example without having any
genuine ability to speak it the
fluencies you have as a language learner
ultimately depend on the depth of the
skills you have cultivated a person who
cultivates overall fluency then is a
person who can comfortably read write
understand and speak a language he or
she can read books and magazines speak
with natives and non-natives in a wide
variety of situations compose natural
sounding texts and watch movies debates
and tv series without difficulty that's
what fluency looks like to me when
people talk to me about fluency though
they often ask about
words doesn't the number of words you
know also affect how fluent you are they
ask how many words do you need to know
to be able to speak a language fluently
it's a good question and a relevant one
of that of course you can't be fluent if
you do not know enough words to read
write speak or listen in a fluent way
but what exactly does it mean to know a
word does it mean understanding the word
in every possible context in every
possible form doesn't mean being able to
accurately use the word on the fly
without thinking about it doesn't mean
knowing every possible definition of the
word it's hard to say maybe even
impossible to say words themselves are
hard to define we tend to think of them
as a collection of spoken sounds or
written letters that forms a specific
meaning but the truth is that meaning is
dependent on context if i say the word
game i could be talking about the board
game monopoly or a deer being hunted in
the forest i could even be talking about
something completely different you'd
never know without referring to the
words surrounding the word game exactly
which definition i meant confusingly
words can be simultaneously full of
meaning and absolutely meaningless
depending on where and how they are used
so unfortunately i cannot easily
quantify how many words you need to know
to be a fluent speaker of your target
language i can however provide some
general guidelines based on my
experience having learned 14 languages
first fluency in a language requires
repeated exposure to a lot of words as
in tens of thousands of words if not
more secondly it is important to know
that not all words are equally useful
some words are used in nearly every
sentence like the or in for example
while some words are hardly ever used at
all the words that will be most useful
for you to know will almost always
correspond to the context you'll most
often find yourself in that's why most
language resources start by teaching you
how to introduce and describe yourself
since you'll pretty much always have to
be able to do that third each of us have
two different vocabularies on our heads
our active vocabulary and our passive
vocabulary our active vocabulary
includes the words we can actively use
when speaking or writing while our
passive vocabulary includes the words we
understand only in context though it is
a good idea to continually work to
expand your active vocabulary your
passive vocabulary will always be bigger
and that's totally fine sometimes it's
enough just to be able to recognize a
word when you hear it rather than being
able to use it yourself lastly it's
common for certain words to have
multiple forms and multiple meanings for
example in many languages a single verb
can have hundreds of forms corresponding
to things like person and tense in these
cases i say learn the forms that you
need in order to communicate but
otherwise do not worry too much about
the rest that's what children do when
they learn their first language and it's
what you should do as well beyond these
general guidelines here are the five
ways i approach learning words anytime i
learn a language with minor adjustments
for specific languages one i do not
count words it's an obvious truth that
the more words i i know or you know for
that matter the more fluently you will
be able to speak beyond that though it's
useless to worry about the exact numbers
if i focus solely on steadily learning
more and more and more words over a long
period of time then i can rest easy
knowing that eventually i'll have more
than enough words to achieve fluency
right two i get massive input i cannot
learn words if i don't encounter them in
my learning activities following that
logic the best way to encounter as many
words as possible is to expose myself to
as much of the language as possible
through massive input as i gain exposure
my brain will naturally and subtly pick
up words and absorb their meanings
through context i gain this exposure
through reading multiple pages of a book
every day right you're listening to
podcasts and watching youtube videos
three i build goals based on habits
instead of worrying about the exact
number of words i need to know to be
fluent i create a system of habits that
will help me maximize my opportunities
to learn new words for example i have
often set goals of reading 2 5 or even
10 pages a day of an interesting book in
my target language and if i can do that
then i know my mental vocabulary of
words will inevitably grow four i focus
on learning the words that are most
useful to me earlier i mentioned that
some words are used more frequently than
others and that makes them more useful
but the utility of a word can also
depend on who you are and what you do as
a person for example i'm heavily
interested in astronomy so words like
spaceship astronaut orbit
and gravity are much more useful to me
than there would be to the average
language learner when i meet with a
language tutor i always choose topics
like this that interest me so i get lots
of opportunities to use these words and
so i remember them better i also learned
phrases and sentence fragments related
to these topics which helps me learn
chunks of words at a time rather than
just one by one five i seek out a wide
variety of life experiences through my
target language have you ever noticed
how children are completely fluent in
their mother tongues even though they
only know and understand a limited
amount of words this is due to something
i call linguistic competence even though
they have limited vocabulary children
develop lots of real life experience
experimenting with those vocabularies in
real life situations they know how to
ask for what they want get attention and
describe the world around them because
those are the skills they need to use to
survive and thrive i like to develop my
own linguistic competence by testing out
my language skills in a wide range of
situations that are most relevant to my
life and if i did not do this and
instead learn my languages only through
reading books i'd have an extremely hard
time doing things like buying a train
ticket
true story ordering food at mcdonald's
or even just having a conversation with
a native so that's it at the end of the
day words do play a huge part in how
well you speak your target language but
how you learn words is far more
important than the actual number of
words you know if you apply the
strategies i've described in this video
then you'll soon develop powerful
systems for learning all the words you
need to be a competent fluent speaker of
your target language if you like this
video you're going to love another video
i made about vocabulary acquisition and
you can watch it by clicking here as
usual thanks for watching and see you in
the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you